[Music]
hello you took just lovers and my
friends this is grunge in here welcome
to the 25th episode of dirty chance
tricks in this episode I'm going to show
you some amazing tricks against Queen a5
Scandinavian defense which arises after
the Mordor
efore d phi e captures defy Queen
captures defy Knight to c3 and now Queen
to a5
this is one of the good reply to the e4
and even in the modern world it is
considered as reliable weapon well to
some extent it's true but I am going to
show you a very tricky mordor which we
can't a lot of tricks if your opponent
doesn't know the theory in depth then he
might end up at the trouble line and the
game can finish very very quickly here
are proposing that you should continue
with the main line that is d4 and now
doesn't matter how black respond so for
example black and play over here c6 or
the most popular move that is Knight to
f6 and after that we are going to
continue with the move Knight to f3 now
if you open and play is Bishop to g4 at
this point then it will transpose to the
line which we are going to see at the
later part so the good point is there
are not much deviation can be done by
the black ok c6 and now we are going to
play this amazing move Knight to e5 now
in order to understand Knight to e5 move
first of all you need to know what is
black idea well in most of the cases
what black wants to do is he wants to
put this bishop outside the pawn chain
before he commits the e6 and Knight - if
I completely prevent this idea now the
main move over here is Bishop to e6
which we are going to see at the later
part
but the first obvious move I need to
consider is what happens if you open in
place
Bishop to fi which in this position most
frequently played move as per the
database and the live book personally I
found that this is a great mistake
and here white reveal his amazing
attacking idea starting with the MU g4
hahaha well believe it or not the only
move to keep black in the game that is
Bishop to e6 which I doubt that if you
open and see this position first time
then he may able to find it okay before
we look at Bishop to e6
let's see what's wrong with other moves
so the first move I want to consider is
Bishop to see it which only look very
ugly but nevertheless white get
tremendous initiative after Bishop to c4
so attacking f7 black is forced to move
he six here what should continue
immediately with the book GFI attacking
the knight and now there are three
queires where black knight can reach to
you amongst them Knight to defy looks
more logical as this Knight is
pressurizing the c3 square and blacks
idea is if I take this Knight then he
can capture back with the epon and that
way his light square bishop would get
liberated now instead of Knight to d5
other mousse I have covered in the pgl
which is available in the description so
kind of go through them after Knight to
d5 white play is very much forceful here
what will continue with the move Queen
to h5 attacking f7 so black has to
defend it if Queen to c7 then g6 is a
very strong reply so at this point g6
looks more natural
after that white we're still attacking
f7 with the move quint we have three and
the only way to defend is now to play
Queen to c7 afterwards why it has this
little move Knight to e4 so simple idea
Bishop captures night and Knight to f6
check and it's not easy to defend this
for example in one game my opponent
continued here
the move Bishop to g7 covering the f6
square but then comes the ultimate shot
Knight to d6 Jack Black doesn't have any
good choice black has to accept this
piece and after that I come up with
Queen Jack King to d8 Queen takes Bishop
rook to her fate and now the simplest is
I captured this dangerous night and
after pawn recapture I captured the at7
pawn so just in the opening not only
black king is misplaced but white is a
clear to point up the second dubious
move I want to consider is Bishop to e4
which has the idea of rerouting the
bishop to the d5 square but here white
has this ultimate reply and in the most
of the ephod Bishop line you have to
remember this move that is Knight to c4
attacking the Queen Queen to c7 and now
you simply take this bishop and after
Knight captures here my recommendation
is you continue attacking on the black
structure with the move Queen to f3
attacking the knight if Knight to d6
then Bishop to f4 is a very strong reply
so here black has the obvious choice
that is Knight to f6 and after that we
are going to keep rolling our initiative
with the move Bishop to f4 attacking the
Queen Queen to d8 and now other forcing
move g5
attacking the knight and after the move
Knight to d5 we are going to place this
Bishop on a wonderful diagonal with the
move Bishop to g3 Black's obvious choice
over here is to play a six to liberate
his other Bishop but now comes another
attacking blow Knight to e5 attacking f7
so black hand is forced black has to
play Queen to e7 defending f7 but once
the Queen goes to the e7 then it's very
hard for the black to develop his King
side pieces and this is exactly the
feature of this game I reached this
position against 2,000 rated player
where I continue
with the mu H for defending the g5 my
opponent responded with the move Knight
to d7 and now I Castle on the Queen side
you may ask well what's the point even
black and castle at this point right
well no can you find out why White has
this dazzling reply nightcap - c6 BAM
well the first cute point behind it that
if black foolishly capture the snide
then after Bishop to a6
that's a checkmate and apart from it
black doesn't have any good choice for
example if Queen tried to run away let's
say Queen to e8 then after night - at 7
we still have a checkmate so considering
all this my opponent find out that he
cannot cancel on the Queen side so that
leaves - the only good reply that is
Knight captures ePHI and after Bishop
captures and now he decided to Castle
but the good point about this structures
are white always keep the attacking hand
here white continue with the move see
for hitting the knight Knight to b6 and
now a retrieving but a good attacking
move Bishop to g3 so still black has to
solve his skiing side pcs and in fact my
opponent played the obvious looking move
at six
attacking g5 but here he get ultimate
shock
Queen to f4 and black position is
completely collapsing
he played Queen to b6 so trying to
exchange Queen by giving up upon but he
completely overlooked White's next reply
that is Queen captures Bishop captures
Bishop captures rook captures and now
simple move C Phi naviga piece
[Music]
okay now let's see the third and the
most popular move in this position that
is Bishop to g6 well against this I'm
recommending that you should start
harassing this bishop immediately with
the MU H for now the same position can
be arrived by a different model so if
you remember at this position instead of
c6 if you open and played the move
Bishop to g4 then you can continue with
the MU ash-tree
and after the move Bishop to H far we
can play the moon g4 Bishop to g6 Knight
to e5 and after the move c6 we play h4
and we got the same plot well as for
doesn't create a threat yet because
black has always the moon Bishop to e4
so accordingly most frequent apply
played over here is e six apart from e6
black has other apply such as
immediately Bishop to e4 and Knight B to
d7 and against each of them I had
covered a sample line which is available
in the PGN so kindly go through it okay
let's consider the movie six well here
many games continue with the mu H file
which I personally believe that it is a
big-time inaccuracy because instead of
that why it has this lethal reply f3 so
completely stopping Bishop to b4 idea
and now indeed by dis threatening the MU
H file so black doesn't have any choice
black has to give his bishop some air
and accordingly at 6:00 or as five fits
in the bill now to illustrate the danger
in this position I like to show you one
of my game against her 2200 rated player
where here he continued with the MU at
six and as soon as s6 or h5 comes on the
board it's time to capture this Bishop
with the night giving black some
horrible porn and now I played a very
strong move Queen to e2 attacking a6
well believe it or not but as for the
position King to d7 is the best reply
but if the 2208 had can't spot it then
how many your funand will spot that
nevertheless I have covered that line in
the PG n but in the game he decided to
play the obvious move King to f7 which
protects both the pawn but it turns out
that this is a big-time disaster here a
white continuous attack with the Mooji
fire hitting the night my opponent
captured the pawn and now I reveal my
nasty idea did the move Bishop to h3
attacking e6
so now there is a no decent way to
defend a6 except the move which is
played in the game that is g4 attacking
the bishop i simply capture this pawn
and after Knight captures pawn captures
there are some open f5 disasters are
looming my opponent tried to defend his
position with the move Knight to d7 I
Castle on the Kings side with a check
kindly note if Knight we have six then
GF I will nab a piece so that's not good
and in the game he decided to run away
with the king that is King to e7 but
after that Bishop to g5 attacking the
King Knight to f6 and now the obvious
move rook a to even and black is
completely defenseless the game finished
very quickly
he played King to d8 I captured a six
fawn and now he played Bishop to b4
which activate my rook instantly with
the move rook to e5 attacking the Queen
Queen to c7 and now the super attacking
blue rook captures f6 BAM black cannot
capture this because at the end he will
be checkmated in the game he decided to
play Bishop to e7 but then comes rook
check and after rook takes and Bishop
captures a7 black has to simply resign
okay so the fourth and the final move I
want to consider is Bishop to e6 which
as per the situation is probably the
best reply but nevertheless against it
I'm going to show you once again a
tricky setup here I'm proposing that I
should play the move Bishop to c4 now
mainly there are two more stride in this
position amongst them Bishop captures c4
is the main reply but personally I think
Knight to g4 required more attention as
it fins upon if your opponent plays
other moves such as Knight B to d7 then
I have attached a sample line which is
available in the PG so let's see the
first obvious reply that is bishop
capture c4 well after that our move is
very obvious we are going to recapture
with Knight attacking the Queen and
after Queen to c7 we are going to play
the move Queen to f3 which sets up a
very nasty trick and I think many of
your opponent will straightaway fall
into it yes
after the obvious move a6 which looks
very initial as it free of the dark
squared bishop but here it's a big time
problem because white has this move in
the picture that is Bishop to f4
attacking the Queen Queen to d8 now GFI
hitting the night and after Knight to d5
White has this wonderful move Knight to
e4 which create a unavoidable threat the
best line goes over here is Knight
captures f4 but after Queen captures f4
it's very clear that there is something
we'll land on d6 after Bishop to e7
Knight d6 check and after Bishop
captures Knight captures King to e7 why
can simply win this b7 pawn as in the
resulting position that is let's say
Queen to d7 and night to c5 not only
white is a clear upon up but black King
is clearly misplaced okay let's see one
of the most critical reply by a black
over here that is Knight captures d4
well here blacks idea is when white
captured this bishop which at first
sight looks very threatening black has
this move in the picture that is night
cap to see fire so black is arguing that
he is a clear upon up and why it doesn't
have any attack to speak off well it's
true to some extent but I think I can
still drum up some counter play here I'm
proposing that white should immediately
regain his pawn with the move Bishop to
c8 and after Queen to c7 Bishop captures
b7 Queen captures b7 and pawn captures
e-file so you can already see that white
has isolated some Queen points and now
to illustrate the further plan I'd like
to show you one of my game against a
national master hear my opponent
continue with the movie 6 I responded
with the move rook to G even so my idea
is to stop his King side piece
development my opponent responded with
the move Knight to d7 attacking Levi
I played Queen to e2 defending the e5
and now he played the obvious move g6 to
develop the bishop on the g7 square
no matter I responded with the move b3
and after the move Bishop to g7 I simply
defend my pawn with the move f4 my
opponent castle on the King side and now
come the strongest move of the game that
is Bishop to e3 attacking the rook rook
to d8 and now Bishop to e7 rook to e8
and Bishop to d6 so you can already see
that that Bishop is wonderfully placed
on the d6 square probably my opponent
didn't like it so he played Bishop to
her fate challenging that Bishop I
simply castle on the Queen side and
after Bishop captures and rook captures
step by step White has improved his
position he continued here with the Moon
Knight 2 c phi i attack his Knight with
the move Queen to c4 and he defended
with the move Queen to b6 okay it's time
to develop so I
played Luke g2d one my opponent
responded here with the movie Phi and
now Queen to d4 so pinning down the
knight my opponent defend his queen with
the MU rook to b8 I played King to b2
and now he played Roop e to see it so
you can already see that black position
is completely tied down and now it's
time to blow up his position after some
thinking I indeed find one of the best
reply in the position that is fi my
apparent capture this pawn and now I
reveal my nasty idea that is Knight to
d5
attacking the Queen he played Queen to
a7 but this straightaway ran into the
tactics with the lovely move rook to d7
so the knight cannot take this rook and
if the Queen takes then Knight to f6
will nab a queen so here my opponent
played rook to be 7 well after that the
tasks become very easy
I give knife check and after King to f8
I wonder if you can spot White's best
reply kindly pause the video and find
out what is the best reply or the
sequence for the white well I hope you
find this wonderful sequence there's a
mating Phi guys and it goes like this
rook check rook takes Queen takes King
to g7 and now Knight to f5 wins the game
on the spot so this game will highlight
the problem in the black cam and how you
can exploit those problems considering
whatever we have seen so far it is very
obvious that if you open played Bishop
to a5 then you should be very very
delighted
ok let's consider the theoretical move
Bishop to e6 well personally I found
that this is a very artificial move and
the way you can exploit this is Bishop
to c4
in other words I'm pretty much
recommending the same setup so it will
be easy for you to remember all this
stuff there are only two good moves over
here and let's see each by turn the
first move I want to consider is Bishop
capture c4 which more or less create the
same trick after nightcap to c4 here
Queen to c7 is a very bad reply the
simple reason is after Queen 12 3 e 6
Bishop to f4 Queen to d8 and now castle
on the Queen side White has completely
finished his piece development where
black has only developer one pace so
this is a horrible situation for the
black so accordingly here black has to
play Queen to d8 after that we are going
to continue with the move Bishop to g5
and after the move a six we take this
night and after Queen takes castle on
the Kings side
Knight to d7 and now Knight to e4
so not only hitting the Queen but once
the Queen moves then we have my check
Bishop takes Knight takes King to e7 and
Knight captures b7 with a misplaced king
and a pawn advantage kindly note Queen
to be it doesn't regain the pawn because
after Knight to e5 we are hitting the c6
and when black defended we can play the
move Knight to c4 and white has
consolidated his extra pawn probably the
most critical variation against Knight
to e5 setup is Knight B to d7 at this
point blacks idea is after Bishop
captures ESET black will take this
Knight and as many pieces are going to
exchange white advantage will slowly
slip away well it's not true because
after Bishop to b3 white obtained a
bishop pair and black position is not
easy to handle there are two more stride
at this position the first more I want
to consider is rook to
which surprisingly enough one high
ranked opponent tried against me but I
think the simple repetition is after
Bishop to d2 black is going to lose in
exchange as the knight is hanging black
is forced to play a route kept his d4 as
after Knight to g6 we have this
wonderful move Knight to d5 which
actually never Queen so rook to d4 is
forced at this point after that White
has this simple but very effective move
Knight to e2 which will NAB in exchange
so instead of loop to d8 s with the
theory black should play the move Knight
to g6 which has a very simple plan to
play a six get the dark sky Bishop out
and castle on the Kings side but I think
this setup has a one good Tropic and the
following model game will show you not
only White has some good tricks along
the line but white attacking chances are
not to be underestimated in this game a
Grandmaster crushes his international
master opponent very instructive Lee
white continued with the move Bishop to
d2 so there is an x-ray on Queen so
black responded with the move Queen to
c7 and now the obvious move Queen to f3
black execute his plan that is e 6 and
after Knight to e4 he responded with the
move Bishop to e7
instead of Bishop captures a 7 if white
capture this Knight
then after Queen captures efore White
Queen is very aggressively place that's
why in the game Bishop to e7 happens
white continue here with the move h4 and
this is a very important move in this
situation because not only this h1 is
hitting the g6 Knight and create some
problems but it also gains space on the
Kings side obviously black has to stop
it so in the game he played h5 and now
the consolidating move c3 black castle
on the Queen side and white played the
obvious move
Knight to g5 attacking f7 which black
defended with the move Bishop to d6 and
now White Castle on the queenside so at
first sight it looks like there is not
much happening in the position and black
is doing very good but in few moves you
are going to see the dark side of this
structure in the game black responded
with the move roof edge to f8 so over
protecting the f7 and now it shows the
problem in the position with a wonderful
move Bishop to c2 attacking the knight
and black has to play a very accurate
moon there's a trick in the position if
the opponent played the Moon Knight to
f4 which at first sight looks very
natural but then the problem start
appearing with the moon g3 Knight to d5
and c4 and no matter however this night
will go black will lose a piece so for
example if Knight to be four then we
have C 5 and after Knight captures 8 and
King to be Vern black is going to lose a
piece so that means black has to go
passive and here he has to played the
only move Knight to e7 if he doesn't
move the knight then pawn structure will
be completely ruined
so Knight move is pretty much forced ok
white continue with his energetic style
with the move Knight to e4 hitting the
bishop hitting denied so black is
obliged to capture this night afterwards
Wyatt capture with the bishop what I
like about this game is every move was
very much forceful and black has to
respond to the white attack ok there's a
threat on h5 so black has to defend with
the moon g6 and now indeed why it shows
why bishop pair are so much important he
continued with the move Bishop to at 6
hitting the rook rook to h8 and now
Bishop to g5
so not only pinning the night but
there's a problem on f7 so black is
forced to defend that pawn fi is a very
bad move the simple reason is after
Bishop to c2
is a concrete weakness on e6 which can
be later on exploited on the e-file so
that's why in the game black decided to
keep his position flexible and played
the rook edge to f8 after that white
continued his attack with the moon c4
another superb move so what is now
indeed threatening the move C Phi and
nabbing a piece so once again black has
to respond to this move and in fact he
did by playing C Phi himself no matter
might took this pawn and after Bishop
takes
can you believe white obtained a winning
position it doesn't look like right but
it is let me show you how so first of
all white exchange one pair of rook and
in the view of f7 pawn Hanks black has
to play King to me a fate now white
activate his rook with the move rook
check and after King to see it fish up
to at six stamp the victory
the reason is after the move played in
the game that is rook to h8 White has
this winning move Queen captures f7 and
not only a six point drops okay let me
show you if Queen to b6 then we have
Bishop to afaid and black is completely
busted and instead of that if black
foolishly take this mission then at the
end we have checkmate that's it guys I
hope you enjoy and lon
this wonderful set up against Queen to
e5 scandal even the set up I have
recommended throughout the video is very
attacking and you will see the potential
of this line as soon as you try to
implement in your game well thank you
for watching this video feel free to
like subscribe and comment on my video
and I'll meet you in my next episode
very soon bye and take care
and here is my vital point in order to
free of blacks queenside peace
development Black has to either move his
D pawn or B pawn and whenever it happens
what we are going to do is we are going
to exchange the spawn and remain a pawn
up for the rest of the game but here
black reveal history after the move
Knight to f6 well it's very funny that
at first sight it looks like White has a
problem with d4 but now black has really
tricked the wide and shows that the real
problem exists on the e4 square